foreign
attack on a member of Congress is
Raising questions about the treatment of
repeat offenders who may also be
mentally ill Minnesota congresswoman
Angie Craig says that she fought off a
convicted criminal who punched her in
the face and tried to get into her
apartment in Washington Craig is now
calling for changes to prevent known
criminals from targeting new victims and
she spoke to our Scott McFarland who
joins us now from Capitol Hill Scott
sounds like a good idea in principle
good morning hey Tony good morning the
crime happened not far from here in an
elevator in the congresswoman's Capitol
Hill apartment complex and she says it
reveals a problem happening in too many
American communities
there was no way in hell I was letting
him up to my apartment Angie Craig says
she spotted kendron Hamlin a man police
believed to be homeless in the lobby of
her apartment complex last week
according to police he was acting
erratic as if he was under the influence
of an unknown substance the encounter
happened just after seven in the morning
when Craig bought her morning coffee a
police affidavit says after Craig said
good morning to Hamlin he followed her
into an elevator trapped her and
demanded to go inside her apartment that
was the moment that fight or flight
kicked in police say Hamlin punched
Craig in the face grabbed her by the
shoulder and collarbone and near her
neck all I could do was throw my coffee
over my shoulder which
startled him
but as soon as he regained he came back
toward me and again it was only until we
got to the floor the elevator was headed
to that I was able to Escape when police
Tracked Down Hamlin they say he kicked
an officer and bit a detective a CBS
News Review finds Hamlin had a lengthy
track record of menacing crimes on and
near Capitol Hill just weeks ago he
served time for striking a police
officer and spitting blood at them also
on his record shoplifting indecent
exposure breaking and entering and more
I got attacked by someone who the
District of Columbia has not prosecuted
fully over the course of almost a decade
over the course of 12 assaults before
mine that morning
and so I I think we have to think about
how in the world can we make sure that
we're not just letting criminals out I
mean it wasn't even in every instance
that he got 10 days or 30 days many
times the charges were completely
dropped before any justice was achieved
at all the alleged attack comes as Craig
begins her fifth year in Congress which
has grappled over the past several years
with Criminal Justice Reform and just
last week debated a bill on how to
better prevent repeat offenders we have
to get these repeat offenders off the
streets we also have got to figure out
how we get people the mental health and
the addiction help that they need
because these people are getting back
out and they're just recommitting the
same crimes over and over and over again
one Congressional proposal just released
would require local prosecutors to
better track how many criminal
defendants have criminal pasts how many
have been given plea agreements how many
have been released to potentially
reoffend as for Kendrick Hamlin he's
back in court here in Washington
tomorrow and his defense attorney did
not return requests for comment me
Scott thank you
yeah I'm sorry she had to go through
something like that but on the other
hand because she is who she is we're now
talking about it but yeah I'm terrifying
what happens very terrified people on
the right have been talking about this
for a long time the need to find a
balance between you don't want to put
people you want to you don't want to
incarcerate people unnecessarily and you
also don't want to take a mentally ill
people against their will and put them
in places that are going to do them harm
however there needs to be a balance
where dangerous people who everyone
knows are dangerous people continue to
be on the street offenders that happen
frequently and that's the issue he said
she was number 13. 13. and also he has a
he's been around the building there have
been trouble yeah